hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba guy is
it's been a while since I've checked out
some videos from my country the
Philippines
oh well half my country sometimes I do
these video reactions to some emotional
Filipino commercials
emotional like are we gonna cry I don't
know sometimes you do sometimes you
don't I don't know what this commercial
is all the sent over to is a very
emotional Filipino commercial I cried
really hard hapless I don't know if I'm
gonna cry there's some I've seen I've
definitely cried at English I think
there's subtitles okay yeah sometimes I
won't cry if I don't know what's going
well no that's a lie because sometimes
through other people's emotions I get
emotional right that's being a human yes
it is you're welcome a smile is the same
in every language I thought that was
pretty inspiring I heard that the other
day and I'm like it's so true bs crap
are you I also wanted to give a
shout-out to our video sponsor of the
real rejects Stardust Stardust is this
app that allows you to do 30-second
reactants for any film TV show or
trailer John and I are using it a hell
of a lot it's really a part of the real
rejects community lisa has not created
an account follow this yet shame shame
shame I didn't know about this anyway I
want my Filipino followers to know hey
follow us in the Stardust at people we
could be the first big ones in the
Philippines on Stardust let's play the
trip there like short films
there we go that's the music I like said
her boyfriend
[Music]
nah that's gotta be like her dad or
something this is already emotional
[Music]
[Music]
get all nice tonight oh wait there's
four legs yeah
[Music]
my problem abandoned ICRP
[Music]
when she dropped her phone away another
[Music]
I remember in the store
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and like his sunglasses yeah it's like
he concede her yeah
[Music]
was the other side
[Music]
you
damn what's he gonna do
[Music]
I was just gonna go around
just so he can get his daughter I don't
know I think he's pretending to be
homeless that Friday the church right
now
[Music]
what whoa
Oh No
no no did he get it okay Casey was this
a commercial for
[Music]
really for the dress
chick chick chat okay yes
expecting that to be for the dress no I
don't know what it was for I have no
idea what that was for they had some
cliffhanger what happened with the coins
I mean I guess we're just supposed to
assume that everything happened okay but
that was a pretty intense moment it was
an intense moment really intense moments
that they just didn't load
I'll admit okay I've seen quite a few of
the Filipino commercials yeah especially
ones from this franchise called Jollibee
they're usually way more the quality's a
lot more up-to-date oh this feels more
like a short film that was like slapped
together you could tell by some of the
audio switches in and out just the way
that some of the Edit is done in the
transitions in the quality it feels like
a much more local I should thing than
the other ones who then I've seen on
YouTube but in terms of like the
technical aspects being often being put
to the side I still really enjoyed the
video though slight misty eyes anything
parents kind of just [ __ ] yes yeah
that was a really nice video really good
message I had no idea what's gonna be
for the dress but it was a great message
a story of a father blind father who's
always being taken care of by his
daughter is now wanting to return the
love and take care of her too so he puts
up all this sacrifice and hard work and
begging just so he can get his daughter
a dress is a beautiful story that is it
that is a beautiful story I think that
should be turned into a film or a short
film it should have a commercial it
deserves a film it does it's called
daredevil oh yeah where he protects the
streets of New York I haven't seen that
movie to show too so haven't seen it I
am a daredevil though yeah okay I think
the acting was good too the guy plays
the dad is really good the daughter was
really good it was when she started
crying I was like I know it's coming
here like the first time yeah it was
really like looking at her I really
liked those shots because evidently he's
blind but they have specific moments
where
based off when he's touching her face
and how he's connected to her where
you're like oh can you actually see her
right now or on his own mind he can put
some image together that's it I mean of
course that was really cool yeah at the
very end the glasses were off and he was
just literally staring at her so while I
feel like some of this is cheesy and a
little forced like when he gets knocked
over by those guys that look like a real
take that took place look at yeah I
still was like you know what this this
its intentions and its message and its
overall story was still very touching so
yeah I had a really good time watching
that parade to the Philippines actually
I want to show you guys a shirt my
sister got me so my sister got me this
shirt it's a bat man in the Filipino
colors right here I've worn it in other
videos I was supposed to work on my next
Filipino dedicated video and I'd
completely forgot but I'm showcasing it
Thank You Megan
X Mary black X follow her there anyway
guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
follow us on patreon it's like a second
YouTube channel over there it's a whole
lot of fun much more raw free form more
importantly if you haven't done so yet
follow Lisa mihalick on the Lisa
mihalick youtube channel where she does
videos of whatever comes to her mind of
what you want to do is that what it is
it's a specifically lifestyle really I
call it it's a little more than that's a
little different than that it's good
different what is it Lisa touch I guess
it's lifestyle but it's a Lisa yeah that
should be the name of it lifestyle Lisa
you heard it here first she she owes me
ten percent of every video